Republican senator Ted Cruz of Texas who
sits on the Senate Judiciary Committee
says he believes judge Kavanagh will be
confirmed senator Cruz is in the middle
of a tough reelection fight we spoke to
him at a campaign stop outside Dallas
about Kavanagh and president Trump's
reaction to Christine Blasi Ford's
testimony how did you get home I don't
remember
how'd you get there I don't remember
where is the place I don't remember
president earlier this week at a
campaign rally in Mississippi mocked her
I've made fun of her that received
condemnation from people within your own
party other senators do you condone the
comments that the president
the president speaks for himself I can
tell you from my perspective it was
incredibly important the Judiciary
Committee provide a safe forum for her
to give her testimony now that being
said the fact that dr. Ford was dragged
into the public by Senate Democrats I
think was really really unethical you
are a legal scholar so given your
background do you think the judge
Cavanaugh has the temperament to be a
Supreme Court justice from what you saw
last week specifically absolutely and
that has been demonstrated because for
over a decade he has been one of the
most respected federal appellate judges
in the country did you think the way he
treated senator Klobuchar was with
respect I believe the behavior of Senate
Democrats was disgraceful throughout
this process in particular they had
these allegations since July they didn't
ask him about it when they met about it
privately they didn't ask him about it
in four days of public hearings they
didn't ask him about it the confidential
hearing they waited until the eve of the
confirmation vote and then they leaked
it to the press simultaneously hurting
judge Cavanaugh on his family and dr.
Ford her family that's not the right way
our art our system of government should
respect people should treat them with
dignity and that's that's not we we also
spoke with senator Cruz about his
surprisingly close Senate race in Texas
we'll hear from him and his Democratic
challenger better--or wharf in our next
hour